I think Tim Tim is printing out too many
strange flavors isn't overkill because I
don't think you can get past the
original I haven't actually tried the
other team time flavors it's a total
overkill like some of the flavors do get
out there know that Tim Tam is like what
Nickelback is to music industry bombed
it ties like an American this year
I'll give it a disturbing zero I play
like I'm gonna hop this is the dark
chocolate
well not something I'll eat with my none
this khana just tastes like a meat slice
that without moving three out of five
three four three and a half to one I
don't like it I feel like it tastes kind
of like a milk powder I don't really
want to swallow it I'll be like four out
of five oh wow
zero to I reckon for one it smells like
something you burn your skin not good oh
my god it gets better with time a one
probably oh yeah one and a half I'll go
into five it's rain off probably one and
a half and out of five
yeah it tastes like off tiramisu it's
just beautiful
tastes like fake coffee though they
could have thought but that's pretty
good I wanna give it got my baby zero
out of five three point five do that
two-and-a-half probably five out of five
I don't know sanitized of anything I
don't hate it it's not offensive no it's
not it doesn't really taste like
anything it kind of feels like a
chocolate-covered Monte Carlo I'm gonna
give it the the middle link or free
outside yeah a great thing I would give
this one a three one and a half I really
yeah I'm really hot brutal give it a
five right off mmm
I have no compliments like the straight
dairy milk chocolate yeah well who
doesn't like a chewy caramel substance
in their mouth three and a half
I'll give before I pray you've got a 4
as well four yeah I'd say a five that's
what I'm gonna get oh really - yes that
is just their best this is the way over
the future you can't complain with extra
chocolate so solid four and a half out
of five five out of five easy boss
I'll give it a four out of cleaning out
of five whoa yeah give it a five as well